valérie pécresse remettra de l'ordre
dans la revue son quinquennat sera celui
de l'impunité zéro pour les voyous et
les délinquants nous apporterons un
soutien inconditionnel et massif à ceux
qui risquent leur vie pour nous protéger
nous rendre obligatoires les polices
municipales dans toutes les villes de
plus de 5000 habitants nous investirons
5 milliards d'euros pour former équiper
et protéger nos forces de l'ordre et
leur permettre de reconquérir les zones
demande nous doterons les policiers y
compris les polices municipales de
nouveaux pouvoirs contrôle d'identité
ouverture des sacs fouille des véhicules
nous moderniserons les équipements des
policiers sur le terrain vidéoprotection
caméra piétons ont embarqué drôme
intelligence artificielle
nous instaurerons une peine minimale
d'un an de prison ferme pour tous ceux
qui s'en prennent aux dépositaires de
l'autorité publique forces de l'ordre
pompiers mais aussi professeur élus nous
déploierons des brigades coup de poing
associant la police la justice et le
fisc pour éradiquer les zones de non
droit avec valérie pécresse nous
mettrons fin à l'impunité pour les
voyous et les délinquants qui
pourrissent la vie des français nous
rétablirons les peines planchers
automatique pour les multirécidivistes
violents et les trafiquants mou
simplifieront et nous numériseront la
procédure pénale pour diviser par deux
le temps de traitement des procédures et
aller vers davantage d'amande
forfaitaire délictuelle nous abaisserons
la majorité pénale à 16 ans pour mettre
un coup d'arrêt à l'inquiétante flambée
des violences des mieux nous frapperons
les délinquants directement au
portefeuille par des retenues sur
salaire au sur allocation sociale nous
exclurons des logements sociaux les
fauteurs de troubles où les personnes
condamnées pour trafic ou violents nous
mettrons en place une participation
financière des détenus à leur
incarcération comme cela se fait en
suisse ou au danemark
[Musique]